The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
All right.
Today we're going to start on a
topic, one of the harder topics
that we cover this semester.
We're going to start talking
about molecular orbital theory.
So this is a quantum mechanical
description of the wave
functions in a molecule.
And we're going to use
molecular orbital theory to look
at the bonding in diatomic
molecules.
That is what we will do for the
rest of today.
We will look solely at diatomic
molecules, and we will look
mostly at homonuclear diatomic
molecules.
At the end we will look at one
heteronuclear diatomic molecule.
And then on Monday,
we're actually going to use a
different kind of approach to
look at the chemical bonding in
molecules that are larger than
diatomic.
So we're going to use molecular
orbital theory for these
diatomic molecules,
and then on Monday we will go a
little bit further.
We will look at bigger
molecules.
And we are going to use
something else.
We're going to use valence bond
theory and hybridization ideas.
But today we're going to deal
with these diatomic molecules
with the molecular orbital
approach.
All right?
So here it goes.
We're going to start talking
about hydrogen,
as we usually do when we start
talking about chemical bonding.
I am going to represent my
hydrogen atom here by this
nucleus here,
a.
This is going to be hydrogen
atom a.
And I am going to represent the
wave function of that hydrogen
atom by a circle because,
after all, the 1s wave function
in hydrogen is spherically
symmetric.
I am going to represent it by a
circle around the nucleus.
So this is going to be 1sa.
And then I am going to,
of course, have a second
hydrogen atom represented here
by this nucleus b and a circle
around it because that wave
function is spherically
symmetric.
And what I am going to do in
this molecular orbital theory
approach is that I am going to
take these two wave functions
and I am going to bring them a
distance of the bond length
apart.
In other words,
I am going to take those two
hydrogen atoms and I am going to
put the two nuclei here,
a and b, at a distance of a
bond length apart.
And I am going to let these two
wave functions overlap.
And these are wave functions.
And what we learned a few weeks
ago is that waves constructively
interfere or destructively
interfere.
What we're going to do first
here is we're going to let these
two waves constructively
interfere where they overlap.
When we do that,
this part of the wave function
here is going to constructively
interfere with this part of this
wave function.
And then the sum of those two
is going to look something like
this, where now there is this
constructive interference
between these two nuclei.
There is a lot of wave function
right here, because we
superimposed those two wave
functions, each from one
hydrogen atom.
And so there is constructive
interference here,
there's a lot of wave function
right there.
And in so doing,
what we're going to call this
resultant wave function here,
we are going to call that the
molecular wave function or the
molecular orbital.
And how we got it was simply a
linear combination of atomic
orbitals.
This is a linear combination of
atomic orbitals.
We just brought those two atoms
close enough so that their wave
functions overlapped,
constructive interference,
and the result is a molecular
wave function.
Now, we are going to give that
molecular wave function a name.
We're going to call it a sigma
wave function.
The sigma designates the
symmetry of that wave function
with respect to the bond axis.
This is the bond axis right
here.
The sigma represents the fact
that this is cylindrically
symmetric about the molecular
bond axis.
That's what that sigma means.
And we are going to call this a
sigma 1s orbital.
It's a sigma 1s orbital because
this was a linear combination of
two 1s atomic orbitals.
But now what I want to do is I
want to remind you that the
physically significant part of
this wave function was actually
the wave function squared.
Remember that?
We talked about taking the wave
function, squaring it.
And that interpretation is a
probability density.
That was what was critical to
our understanding of where the
electrons are in a molecule.
So that is what we're going to
do here.
We're going to take this sigma
1s molecular wave function now,
and we're going to square it.
And that is then proportional
to, or interpreted as,
a probability density.
I will just abbreviate that by
P, but this is a probability
density, remember,
not a probability.
Well, if that is the case,
then I can multiply this out.
Because sigma 1s right here,
that sigma 1s is really equal
to this linear combination of
1sa, 1sb.
That is sigma 1s.
So let me take 1sa plus 1sb,
multiply it by 1sa plus 1sb.
That's what sigma 1s is.
I'm just going to multiply this
out.
And when I do that I am going
to get 1sa squared plus 1sb
squared plus 2 times
1sa 1sb.
That is my probability density.
But now, to make this a little
bit more real for you,
let's plot it.
I am going to plot the
probability density as a
function of the position along
the bond axis.
In this case here,
the nucleus a is here and the
nucleus b is there.
So we have a molecule now.
I am just going to plot the
probability density as a
function of the position along
the internuclear axis.
And what is it going to look
like?
Well, it's going to look like
this.
It is going to look something
like that, where the probability
density is the highest right at
nucleus a and the probability
nucleus b.
Because, after all,
any wave function,
an s wave function,
the highest value of that wave
function is right at r is equal
to zero or right at the nucleus.
So that is what that
probability density looks like.
And I have just been informed
here that the Xeroxing on that
particular figure did not turn
out so well, but that is what it
should read, if you cannot read
it very well.
But the reason I plot this here
is to contrast it with the
following.
Suppose I take just one
hydrogen atom and the other
hydrogen atom,
but I take those wave functions
and I just square them and then
I add them up.
Suppose I take a hydrogen atom
with its wave function 1sa.
I square it.
And then I take another wave
function for another hydrogen
atom 1sb.
I square it.
And I add those two up.
In this case,
what that is doing is taking
two hydrogen atoms and just
taking their wave function and
squaring them.
In this particular case,
what I haven't done is I
haven't allowed any interference
to happen.
I haven't allowed the wave
functions to constructively
interfere.
I did not add up these wave
functions first before I squared
them.
I squared them and then I added
them up.
That is different than taking
those wave functions,
letting them constructively
interfere and then squaring
them.
And you can see the difference
is when I plot this sum and
compare it to that sum.
So I am going to plot now this
sum.
When I do that it's going to
look, well, pretty much like
this.
But then right at the center,
right here, the probability
density for this case,
for two hydrogen atoms which
are now nonbonded,
they're nonbonded because I
didn't let those two wave
functions constructively
interfere.
The result is that this
probability density right in the
center here, that probability
density is less than what it
would be if I let those two
hydrogen atom wave functions
constructively interfere.
And that is the key in this
chemical bond is this term right
here.
It's this term that makes all
of the difference.
This is our constructive
interference.
This is the extra density that
we get because those two wave
functions have constructively
interfered.
That is what gives me this pile
up of electron density right in
the center here.
This is the glue in this
chemical bond.
Make sense?
Okay.
All right.
We have formed,
now, a molecular wave function,
by this linear combination of
atomic wave function.
Now, what happens to the energy
when we do that?
Well, you can imagine what
happens to the energy.
The energy goes down.
We are going to form a new
molecular state.
Let's draw an energy level
diagram.
Energy going up here.
And let me represent here,
by these two lines,
the energy levels of the
separated hydrogen atoms.
I am going to call this the 1s
state on atom a,
the 1s state on atom b.
They're at the same energy.
They are two hydrogen atoms.
You cannot tell them apart.
And each one of them has an
electron.
Once we allow those two wave
functions to constructively
interfere, we're going to
produce a new state.
We're going to call that state
sigma 1s.
And that state is going to be
lower in energy here than the
two states from the individual
hydrogen atoms.
And that is good because if it
is lower in energy,
we've got these two hydrogen
atoms stuck together.
We formed a chemical bond.
These two hydrogen atoms are
not going to fly apart.
That's what we wanted to do.
And, therefore,
those two electrons here,
one from each hydrogen atom are
sitting now in this new
molecular state that we are
calling sigma 1s.
And the wave function then that
describes the electrons in that
state is the sigma 1s molecular
wave function.
That's great.
Everything looks cool,
except now that these are
waves.
Not only can waves
constructively interfere,
but they can destructively
interfere, too.
So we have got to take care of
that case now,
the case of destructive
interference.
Let's do that.
In this case,
what is going to happen?
Well, again,
we have our 1sa wave function
and our 1sb wave function.
And, now, when I am going to
bring these two together to the
equilibrium bond length ab here,
what is going to happen is in
destructive interference this
wave function is going to cancel
this part of the wave function.
When these overlap and I take
this minus sign here,
or I am superimposing two wave
functions with different sign,
I am going to have destructive
interference.
And the result is that the
molecular wave function is going
to kind of look like this.
Right in the center,
here, there is going to be a
node.
There is a node because this
part of the wave function
exactly canceled this part of
the wave function.
Hey, there is no wave function
right there because we have
destructive interference.
How are we going to label this
wave function?
Well, we are also going to call
it a sigma wave function.
It is sigma.
That is the symmetry because
it's cylindrically symmetric
around the bond access.
But, because it is a linear
combination here that is a
consequence of destructive
interference,
I am going to call this sigma
star 1s.
And I am going to call that
sigma star 1s,
which is an antibonding orbital
or an antibonding wave function.
Now, how do I know that?
Well, let's also calculate the
probability density here for
sigma 1s star.
That is going to be
interesting.
We've got P,
probability density,
sigma 1s star,
square it, so I have now a 1sa
minus 1sb times 1sa minus 1sb.
Multiply that out,
so I get 1sa quantity squared
plus 1sb quantity squared minus
2 times 1sa times 1sb.
I am now going to plot this on
my graph here.
This is what I am plotting
right on my graph of the
probability density.
When I do that,
well, way out here,
on one end of the molecule,
probability density is pretty
low.
Probability density goes to a
maximum right at the nucleus and
then it plummets.
And right at the center here,
the probability density is
zero, because the wave function
is zero.
Because we had destructive
interference.
I want you to notice something.
Probability density here is
zero.
It is even lower than this
case, which is just the sum of
two hydrogen atoms,
their wave functions squared.
In the case when the two
hydrogen atoms are not
interacting, the probability
density is some finite value.
But in the case of this
antibonding state,
the probability density is
zero, goose egg,
zip, nada, all of the other
things.
There is nothing there.
This state here that we're
forming is antibonding.
It is not even nonbonding.
Nonbonding you've got more
electron density.
Let me fix my microphone here.
All right.
Nonbonding has more electron
density than antibonding.
This is antibonding against
bonding.
That is the kind of state we
just formed by destructive
interference.
So, where do you think,
in an energy diagram,
the sigma 1s star
level is?
Well, you can imagine where it
is.
It is increased in energy.
It is up here,
sigma 1s star.
And it turns out that the
amount of energy above the
energy for the two separated
hydrogen atoms that this state
lies is about equal to the
amount of energy below the
separated atoms that this state
lies.
These two energies are about
equivalent.
We now have a bonding state or
a bonding orbital.
We now have an antibonding
state or an antibonding orbital.
Now, when do we use that
antibonding orbital?
Well, we are going to see in a
moment, but one case would be if
we had an excited state of a
hydrogen molecule.
In an excited state what we
could do is take one of these
electrons.
And my eraser is kind of wet
here so it is not erasing.
Let me dry this.
I could take one of these
electrons here and populate it
and put it in this state.
That's the first excited state
of H two,
not H, H two.
A second excited state would
be, hey, this is permanent chalk
once it gets wet.
All right.
The second excited state would
be taking that second electron
and promoting it to this
antibonding state.
That would be the second
excited state of molecular
hydrogen.
Now, I've got to tell you that
if you have these kinds of
excited states in molecular
hydrogen, molecular hydrogen
doesn't stick around.
It is going to fall apart.
But the ground state
configuration of H two has these
two electrons here in the sigma
1s state.
I also just want to point out
here what the significance
physically is of the separation
in energy between the hydrogen
atom states and the molecular
hydrogen state.
Here is the significance.
Remember we drew an energy of
interaction for molecular
hydrogen?
We talked about the general
principles, the general
attractions and repulsions that
take place in every chemical
bond, and the result was a curve
that kind of looked like this,
where this is hydrogen,
two separated hydrogen atoms,
this is of course the
equilibrium bond length of H
two, the molecules bonded here
everywhere where this energy is
lower than the separated
hydrogen atom limit.
Well, the physical significance
here of this energy lowering of
this state is,
well, this is essentially delta
E sub d,
right?
This is essentially the bond
strength of molecular hydrogen.
That is what that is
physically.
This energy from here to here,
that's what it is going to take
to pull the hydrogen atoms
apart.
The bond energy.
We took care of hydrogen.
We have two molecular states,
bonding and antibonding.
For the ground state hydrogen,
both electrons are in that
bonding state.
Now let's walk across the
Periodic Table.
Oh, one other thing.
If you were asked to write the
electron configuration of
molecular hydrogen in the ground
state what would you do?
Well, the electron
configuration of molecular
hydrogen then,
the way we would write it is
sigma 1s two,
meaning two electrons in the
sigma 1s state.
And, just to be complete here,
you could write this
antibonding state as sigma 1s
star with zero electrons in it.
That would be the electron
configuration.
Well, now what we are going to
want to do is to write the
electron configuration for the
next molecule as we walk across
the periodic table.
The next diatomic molecule.
Well, the next diatomic
molecule is going to be helium
two.
Where are the electrons in the
case of helium two?
Well, in the case of helium,
each helium atom brings in two
electrons.
Each helium atom has two
electrons here in the 1s state,
so I am now drawing this for
helium.
And the way we draw this
correlation diagram,
as it is called,
is following this Aufbau
Principle that we had for
filling atomic states.
That is, we take the states,
we order them in terms of their
energy, lowest energy at the
bottom, next highest energy,
and then we start to put
electrons in those states one at
a time, starting at the bottom,
starting at the lowest energy,
until we run out of electrons.
So that is what we're going to
do for helium.
What is going to happen?
Two of these electrons are
going to be in the bonding
state, and then two of these
electrons are going to be in the
antibonding state.
And so the electron
configuration here for helium is
1s two sigma 1s star two.
That's the electron
configuration for helium dimer.
But this is interesting
because, look,
we have now,
in this molecular state,
two electrons that are at an
energy that is lower than the
two separated helium limit and
two electrons that are higher.
It seems like there wasn't an
overall stabilization of this
molecule because we have one
state that is lower in energy
and another state that is higher
in energy by the same amount.
So the overall is zippo.
And, indeed,
that is the case.
We've got a tool for counting
or for telling how strong the
bond is, and that tool is called
the bond order.
The bond order is defined as
one-half the number of bonding
electrons minus the number of
antibonding electrons.
In the case of helium two
we've got two bonding
electrons and two antibonding
electrons.
In the case of helium two,
the bond order here is equal to
zero.
When you have a bond order
equal to zero,
what that means is that you
have no bond.
And, indeed,
that is the case.
Helium two has no bond between
them.
Now, accurately speaking,
helium two does have a bond
between them.
Helium two was discovered,
so to speak,
in 1993.
And it was made under really
very special conditions.
And the bond strength of helium
two is a whopping 0.01
kilojoules per mole.
That is for He two.
Whereas, for example,
the bond strength in hydrogen
is 432 kilojoules per mole.
So you can see how weak a bond
that is.
Effectively,
this has no bond at all,
practically speaking.
And so molecular orbital theory
really gets it right in the
sense that it tells you there is
no bond here.
Great.
All right.
Now, what we're going to do is
we're going to keep marching
across the Periodic Table.
Actually, we've got to go down
one row now.
And let's look at the electron
configuration for lithium dimer.
Now, if we're going to bring
together two lithium atoms,
lithium has two electrons that
are in the 1s state and one
electron each in a 2s state.
And let me put them in.
Those are the electron
configurations for the two
separated lithium atoms.
How do we write this electron
configuration?
Well, again,
we follow the Aufbau Principle.
We put two electrons here,
two electrons here.
But now, since we've got these
2s electrons,
what we are going to have to do
is to form molecular states,
molecular orbitals between
these 2s atomic orbitals.
And the 2s atomic orbitals form
these molecular states in the
same way that the 1s atomic
orbitals do.
They're all spherically
symmetric, so they form these
orbitals in absolutely the same
way.
And so you get a sigma 2s
bonding state and a sigma 2s
star antibonding
state.
If you want to write the
correlation diagram,
as it is called,
for lithium two,
you take all of lithium's
electrons and you now put it in
the lowest energy state,
put it in the next highest
energy state and put it in the
next highest energy state.
That is the correlation
diagram.
We ran out of electrons.
We had six electrons total.
The electron configuration
written here is this,
sigma 1s 2, sigma 1s star 2,
sigma 2s 2.
What is the bond order here?
Let's calculate it.
We have two,
four bonding electrons.
We've got two antibonding
electrons.
4 minus 2 divided by 2 is 1.
We've got a bond order of one.
That means we've got a single
bond.
That bond strength is 105
kilojoules per mole.
That is single bond.
It's a weak single bond but
that is a single bond.
What about beryllium?
Let's make beryllium
two.
How did these two get up here?
Okay.
These electrons are the
electrons on the atom.
The lithium atom has two 1s
electrons and one 2s electron.
And this is the energy ordering
for the atomic states in
lithium.
The molecular state for lithium
here, the sigma 2s state,
it is higher in energy than the
sigma 1s star.
This is the correct ordering of
the energies of these states.
I didn't clearly explain that
to you.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Okay.
Now we will go to beryllium
dimer.
Now we've got two 2s electrons.
Again, what do we do?
We put two of the electrons in
the lowest energy state,
two in the next highest energy
state, two in the next highest
energy state,
and another two in the next
highest energy state.
The electron configuration here
of beryllium dimer,
sigma 1s 2, sigma 1s star 2,
sigma 2s 2, sigma 2s
star 2.
The two is cut off here,
but there is a two.
What is the bond order?
Zero.
There is no bond here in
beryllium two.
Now, again, there is a very
weak bond.
It is 9 kilojoules per mole.
But, for all practical
purposes, there is no bond
between beryllium two.
And this molecular orbital
approach gets that right.
Well, now boron.
Boron has got a p electron in
the atomic configuration.
Now what we've got to do is
look at the constructive and
destructive interference between
these p wave functions.
We've got to do that.
We've got to make molecular
states.
We've got to let the p wave
functions, the p atomic wave
functions constructively and
destructively interfere to make
a new molecular wave function.
You ready?
Here is how we do it.
Here is the 2px wave function
or the 2py wave function.
They look the same,
right?
One is just in x-dimension.
One is in the y-dimension.
They've got a nodal plane right
here.
What we are going to do is take
that wave function,
overlap it with the same wave
function, 2px or 2py from
another atom.
We're going to bring these two
within the equilibrium bond
length.
We are going to let this part
of the wave function overlap
with this part of the wave
function and this part of the
wave function overlap with this.
And we are going to treat
constructive interference first.
And the result is a wave
function that kind of looks like
this.
In the center right here we've
got a lot of wave function,
because right here we've got
constructive interference.
In the center here we've got a
lot of wave function.
However, right along the
internuclear axis we've got a
nodal plane.
Well, we've got a nodal plane
there because we had a nodal
plane in the atomic wave
functions to begin with.
So that nodal plane is
maintained here.
I will try this again.
Okay.
Now, this molecular wave
function here,
it is going to have a different
name because it has a different
symmetry.
This wave function is not
cylindrically symmetric around
the bond axis.
There is wave function above
the bond axis and wave function
below the bond axis,
but not on the sides here.
It is not cylindrically
symmetric, so we have a new name
for it.
It is a pi wave function.
And we are going to call it pi
2px or pi 2py.
It's going to be a bonding wave
function.
And, of course,
since it is a bonding wave
function, if we look at an
energy level diagram,
the pi 2px and pi 2py are going
to be lower in energy than the
atomic wave functions,
just like this.
And since the 2px and the 2py
in the atomic states are at the
same energy, the pi 2px and pi
2py, they are going to be at the
same energy in the molecule.
Make sense?
[LAUGHTER]
Okay.
Let's do boron.
Boron two.
Boron has got one p electron.
It also has some s electrons.
The s states are down here.
I didn't draw them in on this
diagram.
I am just treating right here
the 2px electron.
What happens?
Well, what happens is,
we are going to fill each one
of these states with these p
electrons.
We are going to use Hunt's rule
again.
Remember Hunt's rule?
It says that when you have
states that are degenerate,
that have the same energy,
the electrons fill such that
one electron goes in each state
before you can put a second
electron in either one of those
states.
So that is what we did.
One electron has to go here.
You cannot put two electrons in
one of these states and leave
the other one empty.
That is not the lowest-energy
configuration.
And you've got to put those
electrons in with parallel
spins, not opposite spins.
That is not the lowest energy
configuration.
So that is the electron
configuration here for
boron two.
Sigma 1s 2, sigma 1s star 2,
sigma 2s 2, sigma 2s star 2.
And now pi 2px 1,
pi 2px 1. Let's
calculate the bond order,
here.
The bond order is two,
four, five, six bonding
electrons.
Two, four antibonding
6 minus 4 over 2 is 1.
We've got a single bond,
289 kilojoules per mole.
That is a pretty good single
bond.
A pretty strong single bond.
That is boron two.
Let's do carbon.
Well, carbon has got two p
electrons.
We follow the Aufbau Principle.
Carbon two.
All four of those electrons
then are going to go into these
pi two px and pi two py states.
Here is our electron
configuration.
We keep going.
Here is the pi 2px 2,
pi 2py 2. Let's
calculate the bond order.
Number of bonding electrons,
two, four, six,
eight bonding electrons.
Number of antibonding
electrons, two,
four.
8 minus 4 is 4 divided by 2.
Bond order is two.
And we have a double bond.
Let's look and see how strong
that double bond is.
599 kilojoules per mole.
That's a pretty good double
bond.
Remember the double bond is
shorter, the double bond is
stronger?
Our single bonds were at 300,
400 kilojoules.
This is almost 600 kilojoules.
That is a strong bond.
And this molecular orbital
picture tells you that you have
got this double bond here by
virtue of this bond order.
Yes?
You don't, but I am just about
to treat the 2pz.
I will tell you what our
convention is.
Good question.
Here comes the 2pz.
The 2pz atomic orbitals,
by convention,
we are going to put along the
internuclear bond axis.
In the case of the constructive
interference of the 2pz
electrons, in that case these 2p
wave functions look like this.
They were no longer coming in
parallel to each other.
Now they're coming in head on.
That is our convention.
The 2pz is going to be along
the bond axis.
3pz is going to be along the
bond axis.
We're going to bring these two
atomic wave functions in,
we're going to let this part
overlap with that part,
and the result is a wave
function that looks like this.
Lots of electron density or
wave function right in between
the two nuclei.
Here is a node.
Well, these are nodes because
there were nodes in the atomic
wave functions to begin with.
We are going to call this wave
function the sigma 2pz.
It is sigma because it is
symmetric around the
internuclear bond axis.
So that is the symmetry.
Call that sigma.
Now, what happens here?
It turns out that this sigma
state is a little higher in
energy than the pi states in the
next molecule.
There are going to be some
exceptions here in a moment.
Nitrogen has one electron in
each one of the p states.
Let's use the Aufbau Principle
to fill them up.
Well, there it is.
Two here.
Two there.
The electron configuration is
the 1s's and the pi 2px 2,
pi 2py 2
and now sigma 2pz 2.
Let's calculate
the bond order in molecular
nitrogen.
Well, it's the number of
bonding electrons.
Two, four, six,
eight, ten minus the number of
antibonding electrons,
two, four, ten minus four is
six divided by two,
bond order three,
and this means we've got a
triple bond.
Boy, this better be a whole lot
stronger.
And it is.
If you look at the bond energy
in molecular nitrogen,
it is whopping 941 kilojoules
per mole.
We've got a triple bond.
This is a strong bond.
This is short bond.
Now, the next one is going to
be molecular oxygen.
We've taken care of all of the
wave functions,
the molecular wave functions
that we can form from the 2p
atomic wave functions using
constructive interference.
It is now time to form some
molecular wave functions using
destructive interference.
Let's do that.
Let's go back to 2px and 2py.
They are the ones that come in
parallel to each other.
As we bring them in,
and we're going to do
destructive interference,
this part of the wave function
is going to destructively
interfere with this part.
This part destructively
interferes with that part.
The result is something that
looks like this.
We've got another node right
along near the center.
That is a node because of this
destructive interference.
We've got another node here
where the plane of the molecular
axis is.
That is because these 2p wave
functions had nodes in them to
begin with.
So that is what our wave
function looks like.
It has some wave function in
this quadrant,
in this quadrant,
and this quadrant.
This is another pi wave
function because it is not
symmetric around this bond axis.
It is an antibonding orbital.
It is pi star because this was
formed as a result of
destructive interference.
So we have a pi star 2px and a
pi star 2py.
Let's put those on an energy
level diagram.
If they are antibonding,
the energies are above those of
the atomic states.
Now, let's write the electron
configuration for O two.
Here it comes.
There is the four 2p electrons
for each oxygen atom.
We are going to put two of them
in the sigma 2pz,
two in the pi 2px and two in
the pi 2py, and then we are
going to follow Hunt's Rule.
And we are going to put one
electron in the pi star 2px
and one in the pi
star 2py.
We didn't put them both in the
pi star 2px or both in the pi
star 2py.
And we put them in with
parallel spins,
not opposite spins.
Thank you.
You are going to ask me a
question.
Good question.
I wanted you to notice that.
Hey, here is a change.
When we get to Z equals 8 what
happens?
What happens is that they want
to make this tough for you.
What has happened is that this
sigma 2pz has dropped in energy
compared to the pi 2px and pi
2py.
At Z equals 8 the energy
ordering flips.
At Z equals 7 for nitrogen pi
2px and pi 2py is lower in
energy than sigma 2pz.
But for Z equals 8,
oxygen and above,
the energy ordering flips.
Sigma is lower in energy than
the pi.
That is something you have to
know.
It has to do with the fact that
the sigma 2ps has much more
electron density in between the
two nuclei.
That electron density is so
high that when the nuclear
charge is that of nitrogen,
plus 7e, the nuclear charge
actually isn't large enough to
support all that electron
density.
But when you get to Z equals 8,
it is, and those energy levels
flip.
It is an exception.
I mean it is a change right
there.
It is one that you have to
know.
Here is the electron
configuration for molecular
nitrogen.
If we go and we calculate here
the bond order,
what we will find is the bond
order is two.
That means we've got a double
bond, and that bond strength is
494 kilojoules per mole.
Now we have got to make one
more molecular orbital,
and that other molecular
orbital is between the 2pz
states and it is going to be
destructive interference.
When this part of the wave
function overlaps with this part
of the wave function,
we're going to cancel some wave
function.
And the result is that we're
going to have a node right here
in the center.
These are the two nuclei.
Here is our nodal plane.
We've got a nodal plane right
here anyway, and one here from
the atomic wave functions.
This wave function is an
antibonding wave function.
It's sigma star 2pz.
And if you look at the energy
level diagram,
its energy, that antibonding
state is higher in energy than
sigma pi 2px and sigma pi 2py.
And so if we go to write the
electron configuration for neon
two, well,
all of the bonding and
antibonding states are filled.
The bond order in neon two is
zero.
There is no bond,
for all practical purposes,
in neon two.